how many really expected it would end
like this for all the smiles and the
cheers in a hotel ballroom Hillary
Clinton contemplating the end of a
political career
last night I congratulated Donald Trump
and offered to work with him on behalf
of our country I hope that he will be a
successful president for all Americans
this is not the outcome we wanted or we
worked so hard for and I'm sorry that we
did not win this election for the values
we share and the vision we hold for our
country
but I feel I feel pride and gratitude
for this wonderful campaign that we
built together this vast diverse
creative unruly energized campaign you
represent the best of America and being
your candidate has been one of the
greatest honors of my life this
but please never stop believing that
fighting for what's right is worth it
and I still believe as deeply as I ever
have that if we stand together and work
together with respect for our
differences strength in our convictions
and love for this nation our best days
are still I have a class it took just a
few hours last night for expectant
optimism to turn to shattering disbelief
they'd been ready for America's first
woman president but left with their
worlds turned upside down like many
those who shaped Clinton's political
career are wondering how and why she
always wanted to change things for the
better if she wanted to get people
brought her health care she wanted to
help fix the economy I I think she had a
tremendous amount of heart and always
thought she'd be an excellent president
from the moment she launched her
campaign some saw the presidency as her
destiny but polls never showed a big
lead and whatever the dysfunction on the
other side many Americans feel she faced
a bigger challenge she's a very powerful
very successful woman she's a great
politician which doesn't make her maybe
the greatest person ever but I think
she's a she would be a much better
president than Trump I think for a long
time we haven't trusted politicians and
she's been a politician for a long time
but you got to remember like politics is
like making sausage you don't want to
see how it goes into it you want to see
the results a lot of the rural areas of
America kind of fell in love with Trump
and wanted the nostalgia of old America
back and we're better than that so I
don't know I don't know I'm really
speechless I can't believe it I woke up
this one was like this is really
happening
America is stunned as in some other
countries 2016 has handed the political
class a lesson here it was a repudiation
of a presidency which promised hope and
change throughout this campaign Hillary
Clinton was questioned about her
likability her honesty her
trustworthiness
but she was also criticised for not
offering a grand vision a message to the
American people the kind that her rival
was able to in the end what she was
trying to sell America simply didn't
want what the future holds for her is
just one of the many many questions in
today's America Gregg Milam Sky News New
York